même vieil épisodique vénérable à
Canterbury Falconer Tony dans Avengers age
of Ultron il y a tout ce travail
inachevé cette partie de c'est encore un
peu un ingénieur qui veut juste
les aider tous à faire les choses un
peu mieux pour commencer à avoir cette obsession
qui est  pour créer la pièce parfaite,
Tony commence à réaliser que je n'ai pas besoin d'
être dans le costume tout le temps et en
fait, cela pourrait être plus efficace si je
ne suis pas
Travis imminent également pour mettre vous
ne devriez pas vouloir nous devrions prendre une décision cruciale
des démos comme si le jouet j'aime le sherry là-dessus,
il est en quelque sorte découpé dans le tissu sombre
ce n'est pas seulement ce genre de robot stupide,
il a de la personnalité
chose de robot logique mais il est
entièrement programmable DJ espace humain c'était
tout le monde Amoy les poivrons doux étaient des
hypothèses et des lettres merveilleuses que vous avez
construites sur Steve Avery ouais rumeur d'argent
qui paye bas vous attend